[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com push up.com supporting all the
real mothers in this country
since just a couple months ago the one
who birthed you
and ruined her nether regions in the
process
dot com
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
that's a horrible uh what do beverage
got
i don't know what it is is it oh it's a
mystery tastes like old turtle soup that
hasn't been warmed up properly it's the
coffee i make by the way you ever had
turtle soup
no neither have i sounds great we have a
lot to get
so today actually we're going to be
talking right now in the news of course
it's sort of died down a little bit
should dc be a state no we'll give you
the exact reasons as to why it's not a
spoiler alert you may be asking hey why
is it not a state why
well there's a reason for that and
there's a constitutional reason there's
a historical reason the left just wants
you to think it's
racism also remember asian hate crimes
remember those
oh yeah uh i think they've actually been
more committed really
recently in the last week to 10 days
that have not been covered
take a guess as to why comment below
right now before don't cheat
pause it pause it when you're watching
this if you're not watching it live
say why do you think they're not being
covered and then you
you know you watch the rest of the show
spoiler alert correct
uh it's exactly what you think it is
gerald a is here how are you i am well
how are you i'm doing well because
you're taking over the meat segment oh
no
yeah because you really know your stuff
on that oh boy yeah we'll see i'm
incredibly disinterested
ah thanks it should be as simple as no i
it should be as simple as no
but it's not it's as simple as racism
that's true for the lord
yeah uh we have speaking of racism
quarterback how are you i'm doing good
yeah you know about to get our state
back
well the center of the stage oh well
yeah the
the important take what i can get
and then we have uh dave landau is here
of course uh he's here
you have a show coming up in virginia
beach this weekend come out to the
virginia beach funny bone come on guys
it's near dc
except this isn't a place that should be
a state there you go
awesome that's a good point uh before we
move up we also we're gonna be talking
about caitlyn jenner who would have
thought that if you close your eyes
caitlyn jenner would be the voice of
reason for california gave an interview
with sean hannity
uh we'll get into that crazy it's
it's a bizarre week and by the way when
you know it's nothing but k-pop trends
on twitter
it's a slow week yeah yeah so we'll just
have some fun with it
um here's something that just happened
recently a teen
worker accidentally misgendered
uh someone which you notice these
misgendering videos
they almost always go the same way
there's usually violence and i haven't
even seen this one it's never
like you know tom cruise getting squirt
with a flower with a corsage like hey
you're a jerk it's usually how a woman
reacts no no no no
violently like a man you're a jerk hey
you're a jerk
why would you do that because you're tom
cruise and it's funny no you're a jerk
if anyone doesn't remember that was
hilarious he got so obvious everybody
got upset about the guy
water from his flower then he lets
fallon break eggs on his head
and he stole the oxygen from his
co-pilot in the plane and now they
passed out he was laughing about it on
david letterman
the point is you freeze in time once you
go into hollywood
and tom cruise has never become an adult
so uh
this teamworker was accidentally
misgendered it's exactly what you would
think also notice that in these videos
you never hear
the misgendering take place you just
hear the reaction
and uh what a wonderful country we live
in here you go no stop trying to
gaslight trans people and tell us that
we're crazy
crazy you need to [ __ ] be mindful of
other people
and stop being a [ __ ] scumbag and
you're a liar i heard you
stop being gaslighting trans people alex
i'm gonna be talking to corporate
super cereal [ __ ] you okay
that's [ __ ] you're [ __ ] harassing
order pig
no you don't [ __ ] do this to trans
people this is discrimination
i didn't no this is a discrimination
he's just trying to say i didn't say
sir harassing people it's a slur
it really does sound like trey parker
and this is a fake chicken
look i love how now they have the entire
employee committee going what in god's
name
is that thing i'm sorry sir i'm stoned
out of my mind
yes stoned out of my mind selling
chicken
yeah everyone here wants to be dead no
one wants to work here they're all just
like i've seen those videos of how
chicken mcnuggets are made and it looks
like sort of the bubble gum flavored
toothpaste you had when you were a kid
yeah i'd rather be that it's los polios
hermanos and gus is about to come out of
the back i gotta do nine
hours of this and can you just yell at
me the whole time it makes you so much
better
nine hours and then you came in in
madras shorts and clown makeup and i
didn't
know caitlyn jenner will get to the next
night with sean hannity said
oh yeah with pronouns my uh i mean my
mother gets it wrong
it's not this happens all the time look
there are people who are passables there
are people who are not
i always just try and use the name of
the person because i'm not
looking to offend somebody but there's a
there's a strong likelihood with that
yeah person oh i would get it wrong and
here's something that people need to
be aware of here that's not a stable
person i just want to be clear
that is not a stable person a i don't
believe that person was misgendered you
see this all the time they think that it
counts as evidence
and and b look that's not someone
looking to achieve a goal if
if a straight man were to go let's say
an employee were actually disrespectful
yeah [ __ ]
look you have either a goal here where
you want to de-escalate the situation
if you're and you shouldn't be looking
for a physical confrontation you would
say would you
would you call me and maybe slap them
you wouldn't be getting hysterical
solely for the the purpose of attention
this is a narcissist who is looking for
attention this isn't someone who wants
an actual confrontation this isn't
someone who actually wants the manager
who wants to correct a wrong
this is someone who is acting like a
child
but i uh synonym for that is brave and
beautiful yeah
well let's just assume that he actually
did who's the bad guy here yeah the
video shows very clearly that that
person
we don't know which way is the bad guy
the chick is the problem the young the
young person behind the counter because
i don't want this to happen twice
who's wearing sweat filled gloves and
has a mask over their face it's like i'm
300 degrees
yeah i have to dress like a surgeon
while selling you chicken
everything's stupid in my defense ma'am
i thought you were a fever dreamer
kind of like when i first watched the uh
dracula with gary oldman and keanu
reeves i was like did someone slip me
the date rape drug by the way we have a
po box you can send it to me i have not
been sleeping yeah we'll see
it is a great way though to get in for
my drift
you're gonna netflix and [ __ ] put on
that and they're like what's with the
hair
speaking of hair uh so yes this is one
everyone is talking about this
although it's funny if you look at
google trends the trend is bruce jenner
not joking that's the trend is bruce
jenner so what sean hannity interviewed
caitlyn jenner all you hateful searchers
on the googles
about caitlyn's upcoming run for
governor and here's the thing
it was pretty reasonable actually gave
some pretty good answers uh
talked about immigrant talked about the
wall talked about the the power grid in
california
talked about the lockdowns and how
they've harmed people and i'm not look
i'm not saying that
hey every it's a race every crazy thing
that caitlyn jenner has done
and i won't specify which crazy things
because we'll get banned that's true
right
mutilation of one's penis and testicles
is you cannot insinuate that that may be
a tad severe but uh there was also a
little hiccup
here which happened that i just thought
was worth
noting i'm pro-illegal immigration
i i i wanted to organize we really have
to pro-legal immigration
what's that you're pro-legal legal
immigration yes plural legal immigration
sorry did i miss the legal part
thanks for catching me yeah you got my
back sean i appreciate that
yeah well sean does have uh caitlin's
back as opposed to bill o'reilly who
has her front [ __ ] thing sucks
[Laughter]
like jokes on you can't feel a thing
totally numb can you believe she's 71.
171.
wow wow credit where it's due yeah
surgeons now i feel bad for saying that
caitlyn looks
freaky like something you'd find it a
madame tussaud
i don't know how many 71 year olds i
mean honestly oh good for katie she
doesn't do trans people live forever
is that a thing i don't know well
i'm not responsible for that one no that
wasn't against the rule
you're right though i mean she doesn't
look a day over calculus
fresh out of the wax museum you're right
madame
tussos by the way caitlin would you like
to be on the show
the show love you yeah ask you oh i
would absolutely say you look great
yeah for 71. you're a 71 year old woman
yes i said a woman yeah hear me roar i
would say look
in your defense look i'm not into but in
your defense
there probably aren't any 71 year old
women
with whom i wouldn't be repulsed so yeah
is she better than that don't stop
bigger
than the clock listen better than pelosi
okay
yeah so she could pull down some uh some
weighing on a cruise ship
am i right yeah everybody katelyn
tonight is inceptive audience this is a
great way to get into the asian hater
yes yeah yeah we have that later and by
the way hey look just remember
uh asians asian americans we didn't use
you
like the left did we talk about the
rising asian hate crimes and where they
were stemming from
and we've also talked about affirmative
action and how there are quotas and how
asians are discriminated against in
universities but
you are now yesterday's news with the
left so
we're going to keep paying attention uh
and make sure that we highlight the
truth
so another story before we get to dc
statehood what's going on here in the
tournament oh
promoting american jobs plan in
louisiana is what uh joe biden is doing
boy are they bored probably boy are they
bored right now they're just oh yeah
he's going to louisiana to promote
american jobs outside of the ones
shipped overseas because of his economic
policy and support for tpp
okay i'm going to make spices and
above-ground graves yeah
what's a k what's an acadian i'll tell
you i like that firefly but that
princess was a little dark so what
that was princess and the frog oh no i
caught you
i liked it i like that one too little
firefly cajun firefly trying to bang the
moon
a breaking bad reference i'm going to go
and nobody said that i left that's just
because i want to ignore you funny oh
okay that's right uh
just lie and wait you have a meat
segment coming up on dc statehood and i
think all of you are going to want to
hear this gerald really knows
his stuff on that and i haven't really
heard a very good
kind of all-encompassing case as to why
dc of course
should not be a state it was designed to
never be a state
it was never intended to be a state and
that still uh should be the guideline
uh but uh right now this is something
remember the cop who shot rachard brooks
now i know these names bleed together
richard brooks was
in georgia wendy's the one who beat two
cops stole the taser
aimed at his face and was you know um
the victim of
good shooting yeah and then they burned
on the wendy's yes they burned down the
wind of course they should well
he's normal so uh if you don't remember
actually uh
before i get to the story of the update
here here's actually the clip for people
who don't remember and i think this is
important
because then you're not hearing a peep
from the media and i want you to
remember
put this in your memory bank okay maybe
bookmark this specific show because i
guarantee you you'll have the same
situation with mikaya bryant
right lebron james came out the media
came out number one trend for a very
long time then it turns out oops stabby
stab
they just let it go away same thing with
ray shard brooks
right it was everywhere the wendy's was
burning we were talking they were
talking about defunding the georgia pd
and we saw the footage like he did beat
the hell out of two cops including
concussing one stealing the taser and
aimed it at their face in the dead of
night
and he was high as a kite and drunk in
his car had a long rap so they just want
it to go away
don't let it go away and put it in the
memory bank from akai brian let's not
let them do it
to use the uh the wonderful beautiful
brave person at the uh waffle house
gaslight uh here's a clip for those who
forgot what happened with rashford
brooks
you don't remember what kind of drinks
they were no sir all right i really
don't miss that
all right i think you've had too much to
drink to be driving so put your hands on
your back for me
hey hey stop fighting stop fighting
clearly they're just looking to hunt a
man right now apparently stop a little
man stop
tight stop stop
grabbing the taser threw him down
other cops trying to control him right
throws him down here comes the punch oh
dear
remember here comes throws him down here
comes the punch that he punches an
officer
boom boom
and then only there at that point okay
when he aims to take her back because he
gets shot
when he turns back completely in reverse
at that point does he get shot so
things burned down they wanted to defund
the atlanta police of course then most
people
saw that and said uh okay we were sold a
false bill of goods well
uh officer um is it garrett rolfe looks
like
i believe it's garrett rolfe uh the
officer there rolf i know his last name
is rolf he was originally fired
charged with felony murder pretty hefty
unbelievable
uh but won an appeal to the atlanta
civil service board and uh due to a lack
of due process
not having 10 days notice of dismissal
he's been reinstated but he's basically
on suspension so he's reinstated but
he's not working
um the criminal charges are still
pending and of course this means that uh
you have some people protesting in
georgia but not as many people yeah so
he's been reinstated this is an example
we had floyd we had shopping trout
no one wants to talk about this because
this show's the kind of crap that
officers have to deal with
on an ongoing basis and there was no due
process there so we see a clear-cut
example right and don't forget about it
this was in the in the height of all the
things that were going on over the
summer i think where
people just were looking for the next
incident and i i just remember when this
happened i thought if you
as police officers if you can't use
deadly force in this situation you never
can and thinking like this would be
clear-cut
i'm so glad that this is heading it
seems in the direction of him being
fully exonerated and saying hey
sorry are bad you did the right thing
here there was there was a bad situation
that you didn't yeah
what are you going to do somebody's
trying to tase you they can hit you in
the fricking eyeball well i think they
need better training because there's no
world in which two cops should have
their ass kicked never per play right
that shouldn't happen
i'm sorry it shouldn't happen that
should not happen we need better but the
problem is
well then we don't allow chokeholds
right so we don't allow chokes and
people don't remember this the big
problem is with tasers a few years ago i
remember in 2009 to 2012 and so
then they made it where you had to
achieve a certain level of experience
and rank to be able to have a taser on
the force
so now they only have lethal tools
available to them and they don't have
physical training send these cops with
their training that you've seen most
police departments
send them into a college wrestling room
a high school wrestling room send them
into a local jiu jitsu club they'll get
wrapped up like a child with
from people who've been doing it for six
months give them six months training
but you have to allow chokeholds you
have to allow
physical discomfort from police officers
if you want to avoid
death physical comfort is what forces
some kind of compliance
otherwise you see what happened there
and we have a sp we kind of had a split
here in the shaving floyd
situation i think we're all in agreement
there that obviously the cops had to do
something
well yeah i mean they're they they have
a weapon yeah they consider a taser
beating their asses yeah i mean they
actually wanted to take tasers away from
them saying that they were deadly
weapons potentially and we don't want
you to have them but
if they're in a perpetrator's hands it's
not a deadly weapon it's not just a
taser he just had a taser yeah
well he just had a tape the taser was an
extension of his if it's like a
think of it as a pcp arm like jacks from
mortal kombat
with tasers yeah uh that's what i don't
get is he can take that and hurt anybody
and they're aiming it at you what do you
have to use the equal amount of weapon
yeah it's it well they already they
don't have it that's what i mean like
it's not they don't have to exactly
he hasn't it's like ah he got a taser
looks like a good old-fashioned tase-off
boy
yeah [ __ ] well no chase is a cop he's
got a whole utility belt full of other
weapons right then take
no shark repellent no trans pornography
no i mean what what what do you want
police to do
i don't understand like we we can't only
be empathetic to criminals
who have a rap sheet a mile long and who
are currently involved with assaulting
officers empathize with them
i don't back the blue unilaterally i
think they do a bunch of crap that i'm
upset with
specifically arresting people for not
wearing masks which we're about to get
into
but come on i don't look to exclusively
empathize with
lifetime felons who are in the process
of committing assault that could very
quickly escalate
to murder and we'll get to the
anti-aging hate crimes in a sense well
and you're going to lose your license
for six months don't do something that's
going to put you in jail for five years
that's the part that i don't get you
don't want to fight a cop right now you
don't want to or get the dwi lawyer
from texas did you see that guy oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the lawyer said that the judge said
don't bring that in my courtroom yeah
you put like 15 million
uh away for the cartel or whatever oh no
no i know you have to ask something i
thought the judge who said don't bring
the race into my courtroom or there no
no it's like just about the cartel where
he's like i'll just uh
use this money to bribe people and then
he didn't and
and now he's going to jail for 15 years
it's like well that's good there's
nobody in there that's going to kill you
anyway i guess we should drop him off at
the border and be like good luck
yeah have fun does anybody else ever dip
their french fries in a frosty
all right so speaking of mask uh
speaking of masking officers arresting
people
look this is something we need to touch
on here hopefully we don't get banned
for this
uh we say there's no there is no
definitive scientific study and i still
ask no one has sent me this that shows
your mask stubbed in a glove compartment
any reusable mask that you are using in
the way most americans are using it
actually effectively blocks the
transmission
of covid okay find me that not sanitized
masks that are thrown out that are
applied with surgical gloves in a
hospital setting
the study doesn't exist but we can now
go one step further
and say absolutely beyond any shadow of
a doubt
in some scenarios not all masks
hurt they cause harm and we need to
weigh
the pros and cons we're at that point in
our life look it's been going on for
over a year
i think it's time to weigh the pros and
the cons of mask wearing but
the cdc director rochelle walinski the
doomsday lady
said that kids playing soccer this
summer
still need to wear masks here you go the
cdc has issued guidance on summer camps
for this summer
that advises kids to wear masks except
when eating or swimming
you know outdoor activities and sports
they need to wear masks avoid close
contact sports
thanks for throwing the swimming part in
last summer there were outbreaks and
summer camps and the kids
um had to go home they had to um to not
attend these summer camps we're trying
to make it possible for these kids to be
able to have as normal of a summer as
possible
if people are playing tennis and they're
they're far away
we can reckon we can say that their
masks can come
off but if they're crowded on a soccer
field they're on top of each other
they're heavily breathing
we don't really think that's a good idea
right now these are kids who likely will
not be vaccinated
hey guess how i know what she just said
is [ __ ] she just said if girls are
playing soccer and if they're on top of
each other have you ever seen
seven-year-olds play soccer on a
regulation size field
miles away the most likely score is zero
zero and someone shows up with a bouquet
of dandelions okay
i have nieces who play soccer i feel
like she should be looking at her quiz
and larry and telling him not to be
ridiculous
soccer players are right on top of each
other it's against the rules of soccer
to have any sort of aggressivity or
masculine gameplay
let alone with girls god damn you have
to take double the strides
just i mean i'm sorry does the nfl wear
masks when they played how about major
league soccer um how about any of the
other professional sports around the
world
that don't wear masks at all and so now
you're saying that kids are
at unique danger yeah but if you come to
my house and play basketball you better
yeah oh my god it's just him hitting you
with a ball while you're wearing them a
lot of heavy pictures
don't let the fire fool you it's not a
fun basketball is not it just hurts
it's just you're in a mask and there's
tea bags yeah oh
come on what's the drink like i was
saying that uh
that lipton what i was saying is uh um
it hurts it hurts it hurts people so let
me get to this maggie williams she's a
high school track athlete in oregon now
we have multiple examples of this but
this is a more recent one
collapsed at the end of her race because
of the mask that she was
required to wear to be clear she set a
record when she was doing this
so she set a record she was pushing
herself as athletes tend to you can't
compare
yourself sitting in a cubicle or you
know god forbid a government employee
where you're
working in a cubicle all day for a
chicken restaurant right
to an elite athlete who is trying to set
their personal best let alone a state
best let alone a national best to try
and get maybe i don't know a college
scholarship
if god willing there isn't a man who
decided to throw on a maxi dress and
compete in your division
so this girl in oregon uh we have the
clip she was wearing a mask and she
passed out and
hit her face in the ground and i believe
may have suffered a concussion
direct result of a mask here you go
maggie williams just seconds away from
setting the summit school record in the
800 meter
a moment of glory overshadowed by this
moment of concern
williams finished in two minutes and
eight seconds collapsing
as she crossed the finish line williams
blames her lack of oxygen on the mask
she's required to wear during
competition clearly in the past this has
never happened
and then this race that i was wearing a
mask it did happen which i don't think
is a coincidence
her coach echoing that belief saying
this was not a conditioning issue
it was a mask issue it was a different
response than i've seen for kids that
have
collapsed to the track just because they
were exhausted she wasn't sure
where she was oha listened releasing
this updated mask mandate monday
afternoon
the guidance will allow people to take
off face coverings when competing
in non-contact sports outdoors
so um yeah that's that's sad that's
heartbreaking and by the way we did a
segment on this where i went and i
trained at the gym and my oxygen levels
got to what is
what we're told from the cdc what we're
told from american health authorities
was too low
yes hypoxia so i experimented with this
myself if you look at the metadata you
can go to pubmed and see restricted
breathing with masks that of course
oxygen levels are lower
and keep in mind if one person pulls
their mask down let's say cheats there
they will have an advantage over their
fellow athletes that lance armstrong
didn't have with epo when you're talking
about these performance-enhancing drugs
like epo is blood you know inside blood
doping
to increase your red blood cell count
why so you can oxygenate the muscles
right the tissues more effectively
you're talking about maybe a six percent
increase versus
actually having access for oxygen
and passing out for lack of it and
you'll see a trans athlete run up with
her
it just crushes her head while she
crosses the finish line just has the
mask is just some rings with a hole like
xerxes like well good enough for me
i used to be a decathlete but this was
always my real dream
it's alyssa milano's knit mask with all
the holes here's a bumper sticker
vote for kirkland get some smell insults
and tell her she lost her scholarship
by the way this is important not wearing
a mask while exercising
is already in line with the guidelines
you don't need to wear a mask when
running outside by yourself so this is a
perfect example where it wouldn't be
necessary but here's the problem
here's here's what happens when you
create a culture of fear
right and you create a culture of
karen's out there who go oh
why aren't you wearing a mask yeah why
aren't you on your mat what well this is
what happens
even if it's in line with guidelines you
have enough parents who complain who go
to the parent teacher boards
and so the coaches go i just don't want
to deal with this heat i don't want to
be fired because
i'm following the guidelines but they're
mad about it you know what i had this
one i was at by the way
a restaurant and i had a cigar okay
i had a cigar and a lady came over and
said i can smell you think he's the guy
from over here so well you must be
really sensitive because it's not even
lit
i was going to meet someone afterward at
the cigar lounge yeah yeah
and this is just what and they
complained and imagine if that person
had the authority to remove
my livelihood because they have an
opinion and they think that everyone
else is anti-science by the way hit the
notification bell
because uh that doesn't mean a whole lot
if you're subscribed anymore
and uh the best thing to do is look
we're a live show monday through
thursday
10 a.m eastern okay and uh over under on
youtube changing the live algorithm
because they don't like seeing us being
the top three out of five
in any given week you make a great point
though it really is because it is a
culture of fear and
you see somebody running down the street
especially wearing a mask it's because
they're afraid to get yelled at
yeah it's the only reason they're
wearing it or their virtue signaling in
which case they're my enemy
well yeah they're afraid to get yelled
at but they're also afraid to be out
into their workplace so they're saying
oh you got to fire this person or
ostracized in the community it's stupid
it's definitely like communist china we
have an exact example of that so none of
this stopped even though it's within
guidelines
new hampshire track coach brad keys from
being fired for not requiring his
athletes
to wear masks this is from within the
last month brad keyes was
fired this week as the track and field
coach at pembroke academy in pembroke
new hampshire
and he has been outspoken about it
online i made my choice he made his
key says he was not going to force his
athletes
to wear masks while competing masks
restrict
breathing there's no question about it
especially think about
running full speed the wind is in your
face it's shoving the mask back
into your nose and your mouth gets you
really tired especially on
you know it's going to get up to 80
degrees soon and it's going to be really
hard for us to
to keep doing what we like to do the new
hampshire interscholastic
athletic association's outdoor track
guidelines
recommend that athletes wear a face
covering
during competition okay first off
we just had an example of a cop who was
murder felony right felony murder right
who
didn't have due process this guy no due
process he was in line with the
guidelines scientific guidelines by the
way so were we in the video that got
removed on our 15 uh
day of the anniversary 15 days to
flatten the curve removed from youtube
because it highlighted the guidelines
back then which go against the
guidelines today
is there justice for this guy people say
oh cancel culture consequence culture
the man was cancelled for being pro
science and following
the guidelines this is important that he
just said
oh wearing masks in impairs breathing it
impedes breathing
that's a controversial statement have
any of you heard of training mask i
think you have this this is something
they sponsored the
not that one but they sponsored the ufc
this whole idea was a little training at
altitude which by the way
is a scam it doesn't work all it does is
make you weaker for longer periods of
time much like crossfit
or being a professional soccer athlete
it doesn't actually work you have to
live at elevation for a very long time
to get the benefits and you lose
it very quickly the point is that's
anti-science making runners who are out
there by themselves where masks is
anti-science
and people are losing their lives for
being and losing their livelihoods
sorry but you know what hey why do we
separate them yeah
for a long time in the world we didn't
separate lives versus livelihoods
try and if you went back to a native
america you know the the the culture
that uh left beautiful
so loved to glorify if you went back and
said hey i'm not gonna kill you
i'm gonna remove your land i'm gonna
remove your property and remove your
ability to make a living also i'm gonna
take all your weapons and if i
see you hunting we're gonna put you in
this uh wicker cell
you'd be scalped before breakfast
what is it what else is left but we've
now separated it because you don't need
a livelihood the government can be your
livelihood but let us remove it first
um well and he basically he didn't say
that you can't wear a mask he just
left it up to them to make up their own
mind oh well they say
that they had to wear them i think
that's that's exactly what the guys
said in governance yeah right and this
wasn't last year this was april well let
me let me just
before we move on here i want to make
sure that i get this straight so you
have to wear one while running
but people eating food next to each
other if they're sitting down don't have
to wear a mask if they stand up to
go grab someone from the napkin
dispensers they do have to wear one
if you wait in line at the restaurant
you need a mask but if
you don't
[Music]
that makes perfect sense
also i have a strange urge to download
microsoft uh
paint yes anything microsoft
to divorce my super rich husband yes
start a measles pandemic
i'm going to invest in vaccines what
happened
i don't know why is iced tea on the
screen whoo well anyway
does he have to say yes to everything he
does
he just makes this legit commercial look
like he's walking through a chop shop
i know right this is one of the dumbest
commercials it's like and i'm iced tea
and it's like
i was just about to put a shark tank
into chevrolet that's
useless says you yeah exactly
that could really hurt someone yeah
probably no it wasn't exhibit don't tr
don't it wasn't exhibited no
exhibit was the host dj funk master flex
was the actual guy who worked at the
garage
sure are out of touch with your culture
go talk to your cousins
uh hey by the way before we move on here
uh crowdershop.com we have a mother's
day stuff going on there and i think
there will be a sale on some of the
women's gear so you can go and support
uh if you have a mother you have a wife
you have a soon-to-be mother it's a
great place uh
to you know go buy stuff hey i found my
wedding ring by the way wait you lost it
i didn't even know i lost it the only
time i take it off is going to in may
the gym in jiu jitsu okay and uh i found
it
it was it was stuck behind a windowsill
no it wasn't know where it was so um
watch the show weekdays monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern
hey here's another story this one's
interesting do you see governor whitmer
you love her
i love her she won the jfk library's
covid courage award i wish that wasn't
the i can't say that
okay go ahead and leave it there
i think we all jfk library covid courage
awards let it lay like brains on a dress
yes nazi [ __ ]
so the tweet from the jfk library
announcing her win reads
in the face of backlash and threats
governor whitmer invoked emergency
powers to contain the spread of the
virus
issuing early controversial orders to
close schools and businesses
mandate mask wearing and ban large
gatherings among other measures to keep
people safe
um yeah backlash and threats because you
killed their grandparents
and their business and their businesses
by the way let's also uh make sure she's
winning an award right now um
her state currently leads the nation in
new new new cases nude cases as well
hold it so 450 you can bring this up to
here it's kolaji
uh token on saw 450 415
increase in cases from february to april
do you have this collage yeah bring it
up
uh vetoed the bill to direct covet
positive patients out of nursing homes
because she wanted them in nursing homes
and she purposely put
young covid patients into senior living
homes with old people
which is why they've had these horrible
numbers oh my god now let's contrast
that with
governor desantis by the way who's who's
actually taking steps and of course
they're better off than michigan even
though
governor whitmer tried to say that the
reason they have an outbreak is because
of florida despite the fact that
florida doesn't have the same outbreak
michigan does
oh i just want to hurt myself let's just
go to the clip of desantis this is what
an actual
real quick that they lied and said that
the c on the award stands for covet
descartes sorry i know what i'm going to
do i'm going to sign the bill
it's effective july 1st i'll also sign
an executive order pursuant to that bill
uh invalidating all remaining
local emergency covet orders effective
on july 1st
but then to bridge the gap between then
and now i'm going to suspend
under my executive power the local
emergency orders um as it relates to
covid um
i think that's the evidence-based thing
to do
well i thought that was important yeah
evidence
no miami-dade yes you think that it
would you think it would matter for
example evidence and guidelines that you
shouldn't wear masks while engaging in
high-intensity aerobic activity
or uh you know putting members of the
crips
from inner city detroit into senior
living homes that that could result in
unsavory outcomes uh but no
you're just anti-science i wonder what
the criteria are for this award that she
received
like there's got to be some kind of an
objective standard right like oh you
enacted emergency powers well okay well
tons of people
did that yeah and really but it doesn't
mean anything but you didn't actually
do better the entire state is in a it's
in a state of stockholm syndrome yeah
you look at the people who still like
governor whitman
go anywhere outside of michigan anywhere
outside of michigan you will see
that it's better so many businesses uh
that
i'm on an email list of and i don't know
how but whatever
but they just send you an email just
saying look she recommends that we do
another two weeks
no the answer is no yes yeah you can't
keep doing this
go to toledo it's better in toledo and
that's probably the only time i'm ever
going to say that for michiganders
that's the only time
anyone has ever said anything nice about
toledo that's true the zoo is better i
hate to say is the zoo better yeah
it's not as nice as the latest not a
whole lot of award criteria you
basically just have to be a living
american
and that's pretty much it so there's
actually a section with criteria they're
like oh yeah well i don't know just give
it to her
throw it over there like you're
responsible for old people getting
punched by gang members here's some
golden gloves
actually i think cuomo's a little pissed
off he's like i killed more old seniors
than you that should have been my award
yeah you know how many people i took out
way more
yeah now show now so whitney you can't
hold the candle to me no i think we'd
both be better off if you show me your
tits
yay my brother sits next to a crying guy
yeah
offended by everything one of them uh
one of them dark guys you know but hey i
don't got anything against them
different strokes
yeah but if he dated my sister i'd give
him a slap
just a backhand you know to keep him
honest
30 years in prison you know make a
lifetime movie about it let me sorry i
gotta go i gotta go pin some masks to a
wall
i'm getting [ __ ] done yeah you like that
that's gonna be a blanket like the aids
quilt
oh man they really did that hey by the
way right now people who are watching
right below here hit that share button
and this lets you share it on twitter on
facebook wherever you are
rumble i think i don't know if that's
directly from youtube but because
sharing
is caring unless you're a communist in
which case it's just robbing people of
their personal property and autonomy
and i do have a question for why do you
think again pause it don't
don't don't do the cheat sheet where you
listen to gerald after this why do you
think the left wants dc desperately to
be a state
this is something that kind of comes and
goes but there's a really intense push
right now sort of like with the court
packing
uh and uh i wanna hear from you pause it
now
you can continue watching gerald this is
a segment that you've been pretty
passionate about yeah we brought this up
uh gosh i don't remember how long ago
and i did some deep diving into it and
found out like there's just no basis
for this argument for them to be a state
but i'm going to give you some of the
things that they're going to say
are reasons well first let's go yeah
first we do have uh
just so you don't have to take my word
for it or gerald's word for it
it's all over the media uh we have all
the sources available at
lidarwithcredit.com we try and do this
just so people know if we're actually
addressing a claim we try and find
the claim from those people so that
we're not making it because brian
stelter will say well republicans say we
want to kill all blacks and you're like
oh they've never said that well i said
it for them
so that's why i try to trust it sort of
show them saying yes go back to your
purse
you should throw more confetti yes he
should every time he ends the show what
if he was just an amazing
yogi who could fit in sorry i have to go
for my slumber and fits in its purse
carry me to my work desk like rivers
cuomo in a box circa pinkerton okay
let's go to a montage where you can see
uh them making this claim that it needs
to be a state
by voting for d.c statehood the house of
representatives
reaffirms this truth that all deserve a
voice in our democracy to hear
congresswoman holmes norton talk about
equality surprise those pearls don't
weigh the front of her head down like
that
because of equal representation in the
congress 54
of the american people support statehood
for their nation's capital
as a result of the he sees the state
charlie brown they learn
what they did not know that the
residents of their own nation's capital
oh my gosh oh my gosh all right look so
first off dc was never intended to be a
state in federalist 43
that's eleanor norton eleanor we're
going to get into you yeah we'll
burn victims okay according to
federalist 43 uh james madison wrote i'm
going to read it here the indispensable
necessity of complete
authority at the seat of government
carries its own evidence with it without
it a dependence of the members of the
general government on the state uh
state comprehending the seat of
government might bring on the national
councils an imputation of all
or influence read that as them having a
little bit of power over the federal
government right and we'll talk about
that in just a second as well
another truth in article uh 1 section 8
clause 17
of the constitution specifically
prohibits dc statehood so we've got
another overlay there
to exercise exclusive legislation in all
cases whatsoever over such district not
exceeding 10 miles square that's really
the only thing about dc you can't make
it bigger than 10 square miles you can't
build higher than the capital
that's true too right what is it 666
feet yeah
as may by a session of particular states
and the acceptance of congress become
the seat of government of the united
states all right
so the reason that this is all an issue
is because a bill just passed the house
and is going to the senate right so
everybody's talking about it right now
it's the cause du jour essentially of
the democrat party they're saying
there's no representation well
dc already does have representation
there are three electoral votes
they get a delegate to the house and a
mayor who works with congress whether he
wants to or not he gets a little pissed
off about that from time to time yeah
another part of this is when the dc
mayor isn't smoking crack
yeah yeah that does happen so you might
ask this question i got these
cheeseburgers
you might ask the question okay so who
is dc's representative to or delegate
to congress well that is miss eleanor
norton oh right let's go back to uh
it's uh this is the charlie brown
look-alike kind of a little bit yeah
okay eleanor norton she wins
what's wrong with that idea this is a
democracy and nobody's asked marilyn
about that
ballon gave the land maryland gave the
land that's christopher lambert
for the nation's capital you can't go
back to where you forgiven
irretrievably and where they don't want
you back
look there's only one option left that's
the statehood option
across the united states today
americans are taking down the remnants
of the confederacy
as symbols of inequality just as the
house of representatives
is rising up
it's spitting it out to ensure equality
for all citizens
every section of the country are united
on the principle that
is 51 the age of her grandson
of responsibility this woman's like 400.
such as paying federal income
taxes i don't know that first one did
you hear when she was laughing
the host thought he should start
laughing he sounded like like
christopher lamp you know we were just
talking right now
kamala harris before kamala harris i
guess right
so i mean this this isn't the most
logical argument they don't want us back
did you hear her say that in the clip
they said talking about maryland
they don't want us back like you may
have tipped your hand there just a
little bit you're really
sorry you really assume racism
everywhere yes pretty much
that's not a place that i would assume
they're like ah
we don't want you we're uh we're you
know we're one of those southern
confederacy states not so much right
okay so let's just get a little bit of
background on her in 1990 just
months before she assumed office at in
dc
as the representative it was revealed
that norton and her husband had failed
to file dc income tax returns for i
don't know what seven years 1982 to
1989.
some would say that that is an important
thing to remember put that on the to-do
list
she's like an untalented uh person of
color willie nelson
yeah exactly exactly then in 2010 if
things
you know couldn't get worse a voicemail
was leaked of norton using her office
and influence to
shake down lobbyists and before we go to
this clip i just want to
we're going to get again to the macros
to why dc can't be a state but it's
important to know that this person
is the spearhead right this person is
the one who's really pulling the strings
this person is one who has the power to
influence people
in washington dc and if look you might
be a a liberal you might be a
conservative you might be a libertarian
you might be uh donald trump supporter i
know that we have different factions
different
political stripes who watch this show
but when we talk about the elite
we are talking about career politicians
who live in dc
don't pay taxes and then use their
position of authority
to uh shake down lobbyists for cash
here is the audio frankly uh a surprise
doesn't see
that we don't have a record so far as i
can tell of your having given
to me despite my uh long and deep
uh work in fact it's been my major
wow work this is a porn video
essentially in your sector i am i'm
simply
candidly calling to ask for a
contribution the senior member of the
uh committee and a subcommittee chair
about it intended to raise uh
contributions
frankly uh done my homework to ask for a
contribution
earlier by asking for one now
women particularly uh need
contributions particularly those of us
who have the seniority and the
chairmanship
why didn't anyone coach this lady and
it's not that she wasn't coached on not
using the word contribution
you know they would say like use words
like i don't know you know you know
maybe uh
maybe uh give me a little something
something i don't know maybe treat
eleanor you know treat sugar mama right
you know something like that it's that
she is so not worried about
accountability
because she hasn't paid taxes because
she isn't beholden to actual
any kind of private sector employees or
profit motive that she's like yeah hey
look
give me some money and you you know what
they're there
there there are actually a few other
democrats involved in that scandal in
2010 like nancy pelosi
notably was one oh wow the reason we
didn't include her is because when we're
talking about eleanor too
no one else was that dumb to leave a
voicemail yeah
yeah exactly i mean she's literally the
female version of rod blagojevich right
he's sitting in jail pissed off because
she's still out there so really yeah
that's the whole point of this let's
give
that corrupt person who's less than
smart shall we say
power in the house because that's
exactly and like i said the reason that
this segment
just is so intensely uninteresting to me
because i researched it a long time ago
thank you stephen no the sniff test is
when people say why isn't dc a state you
go why isn't dc a state
and then you just look into a brief
history you go oh because it's meant to
be a place where people are impartial
you have some people right now in the
media they go
why aren't they in dc why aren't they
paying their taxes in dc because
what we're supposed to have are people
who pay taxes in their home states
and represent their constituents going
to a neutral territory
the state capitol that is the reason for
it it wasn't by accident and i know
people who can't be bothered to
read the constitution will assume that
it's an accident
but it's not and this has been
reiterated many
times so the fact that they're look
they're assuming you're dumb
they're assuming you are stupid that you
will just go yeah
why isn't dc estate and then google will
join in and all you'll find when you run
a search is dc should be a state
it won't show you the historical context
or how the founding fathers
and then people who ran this country
thereafter were expressly against dc
being a state for a multitude of reasons
yeah well and they'll make what sounds
like a reasonable argument
representation
that's what we just covered right oh
well okay well that's why we left
england we didn't get the representation
we wanted and we were taxed
got it that makes sense well it's a
little different than what they claim it
is the next claim that they make is
actually about population well look
the entire state of wyoming only has
about 600 000 people they'll say and
residents of dc that comes to about 700
000 people of course we should be a
state
well actually that does it at 600 000
yen yeah
last time i got a speeding ticket was
leaving my wyoming and he said
was it yeah he said why were you going
90 to get the hell out of wyoming
i didn't feel like there was a chance of
hitting anything yeah there was nothing
they call it the big sky state because
you'd rather look up
well look so it doesn't really matter
again how big an area is that's not
really the qualification for a state
the federalist papers and constitutions
specifically sectioned off dc to be a
federal district
and non-partisan seat of our government
right about 800
000 people actually work in dc but only
30 to 40 percent of them
actually live in dc ah that's a that's
an interesting fact that they probably
aren't getting
what they'll argue is well most people
who live there are poor black people and
you don't want them to vote that's what
they will argue that's not true at all
right and so they bring up this argument
about population oh there's 700
000 people well in fact in 1950 there
were over 800 000 people that lived in
dc was it still a crime then that they
didn't have representation were you
still beating the defenses and saying
look we've got to have a state of dc
here
yeah new york has a population of 20
million
people some would say that that's more
than 700 000 should they also
say well hey we want to be a state now
right so if population was the only
barometer that we used for this then
that would not really work as an
argument anyway
new york city new york city new york
city new york state is obviously a state
when you have new york you mean this to
be fair i think that's an over count
because they were
they did that by satellite imaging by
imaging and they counted the piles of
hobo [ __ ]
that's true san francisco population has
gone way up as well
and it's 38 billion just like count the
rats
just like you know how how uh spider-man
would be useless in the suburbs of
course well yeah
predator would be useless in san
francisco it's heat seeking
others he'd be thrown off by all the
cuban [ __ ]
yeah but that was before it was all the
crap back then the hobos had the common
decency to use the corner like an animal
that's true
there is no excuse by the way no excuse
for [ __ ] on the sidewalk where you
stand use an
alley what if it's pelosi's driveway
well okay now what
can you imagine can you imagine being
predator and you like turn on your
your vision you're like oh [ __ ] it's
everywhere all red just just arnold
rolling in it
where's the dreamer the leaf blows my
[ __ ] off the driveway
oh my gosh all right all right okay okay
look this has happened before and this
is another argument
this is an argument that was actually
used against one of the congress uh
women
and they said oh you're actually in the
district of massachusetts so they're
saying
that it's been done before so we can do
it again well the truth is maine was
formed from massachusetts yeah they're
trying to say that it's been
forth maine and west right so you have
people to do again virginia uh gave us
west virginia thanks a lot for that
uh but they agreed to it as is
constitutionally prescribed right so if
you're confused about the issue article
4 section 3 makes it very clear
new states may be admitted by the
congress into this union but no new
state shall be formed or erected within
the jurisdiction of any other state
clear nor any state formed by the
junction of two or more states or parts
of states without the consent of
legislatures of the states
as well as congress right so those
states have to agree
we're going to do this in their
legislatures then it goes to congress
you can't just sign an executive order
and you can't just push for it randomly
so you need to find a state
who is willing to if a willing partner
if
maryland is if maryland is kind they'll
take them in as one of their own they
will not do that and in this case
maryland gave up part of its land to
create dc so maryland can't give
permission to make it a state because
it's no longer
there that's what she was saying they go
juana's back
correct but it's just this it's just the
city it's just dc
no one wants you no one's specific i
mean you specifically
but we get your connotations i'm just
agreeing with you for different reasons
because you're horrible so i think
there's one argument that kind of
supersedes
all arguments in this case why was dc
put into the position as a district
instead of a state in the first place
why was it not located somewhere else ah
it actually was the founders moved the
capital
to dc from philadelphia to make sure
that the host state couldn't exert undue
pressure like we said earlier on the
federal government i mean
really imagine a liberal-controlled
state of dc
during donald trump's presidency it's
like oh sorry donald your water bill is
a little bit late right now we apologize
maybe you can take a dip in the potomac
you jerk
right they would do something like that
or oh the stoplights they're out we're
really sorry donald you can't have your
parade
right he would they would definitely do
something like that and so what they did
is they said look we're going to form dc
out of land given by both virginia and
maryland
to make sure it's not in either one
virginia got their land back in 1846
but it never went back to maryland we
are left with that piece of land right
now so
final reason for them wanting to do this
there is no other reason that makes any
sense
i want power right now in the senate
what do we have we have an equal sharing
of power
not a whole lot's getting done because
we have people crossing the aisle
with these crazy ideas and they're
saying if we have a state
we get two more senate seats forever
controlled by dems
that is the only reason and by the way
what's important to note the also the
reason for an aggressive push because
we know that this has happened after the
census right texas game did texas gain
two seats or they gained two two and
several two in the house two now sorry
and then uh other uh states i know new
york lost one california i don't think
anything
lost two but it was a net gain for
republicans right now here's the thing
for sure that was based
on population right and hey new york if
you
just allowed your police officers to
stop 80 of the extra murders
you wouldn't have lost a seat yeah let's
talk about shooting yourself
and all of your citizens in the foot so
this is what
look at the difference they gain seats
in the house with this census because of
population within the states
appropriate and now the power grab
comparatively is we don't want to
involve the states
it's not actually based on it's not
based on historical precedent
we just want this because you know what
we're losing some power now because
people are leaving
liberal areas for conservative areas we
have to try and shift this balance
right and dc was never supposed to be a
place that you were supposed to go and
live your life you were supposed to go
represent
your constituents and then go home right
right and you'd be able to vote in your
home state and stuff like that as well
but so
lest you take our word for it eleanor
norton comes to the rescue and was even
asked this point blank on good morning
america
and uh she kind of pulled the biden
where she answered a question she wasn't
asked yeah she started quiet
out the filibuster yeah here you go
here's
here's your uh you're a representative
charlie brown talking about filibuster
there are republicans in the senate who
are you're such a black hat eleanor
more seats to the democrat side of
things what do you say
to them give me my football what i say
to them is that i think the
the tomb is bursting open
we saw the senate late organizing
and the reason she just exited
the reason democrats got hold of the
senate this time
was because of the filibuster and the
republicans were passing
nothing uh-oh i think she said what she
was
she says the quiet parts out loud and
allows them to be recorded on television
and voicemail
right and now now never say anything you
don't want to read back to you in court
and she
leaves it she committed the cardinal sin
of being honest
as a politician and you can never do
that apparently right because the the
abolishing the filibuster you know that
they've been talking about this to try
to get things through chronicles that is
the first step democrats need to take to
make sure that their agenda goes through
expanding mail and voting crazy gun laws
free college why are you left this topic
of dc statehood
uh as well he's laughing at joe lewis
he's got the bat dog here going on
i'm not let i i find things fine joe
lewis stop it i'm sorry i'm here
for the the humor you're no you're not
you're here for all of us well this is
actually the first time i've learned any
of this
because people have asked me questions
and you just started going well and
that's look that's the reason that we're
covering this because right now they
assume that you're not going to take
five minutes and look into this and
realize that this is stupid well i
realized
i've always realized that's the point of
equality and that's what i don't get
equality good except
in dc bad right well i mean basically
that's what the argument has been right
i've disabused you of that notion i love
desantis saying yeah by the way
and look there is a solution to this if
they really are worried about
representation if they're like guys this
is
absolutely unfair we have to take care
of it okay give the land back to
maryland just like we did
for virginia right gave them the land
back keep all of the federal land let
them do their own thing like they want
to do but give all the other land back
to maryland then
maryland's legislature has to vote to
make it a state then congress has to
approve it then the senate has to
approve and goes to the president's desk
this isn't complicated that is the only
way that just sounded very complicated
no
what you just said sounded very
complicated let me simplify it for you
uh they're not a state because it was
never designed to be a state
and they wanted it to continue not being
a state so that people could represent
their states in an
unbiased municipality that's exactly
what it is why it exists and they said
oh by the way we're going to put in
safeguards to make sure that it
continues that way
that's it it's over stop making an
argument that dc needs to be a state
it's the same tire
they want dc to be a state pack the
court
do away with the electoral college
federal law
uh voter id voter yeah we don't want to
have voters think about this for a
second
unbelievable we're going to release
serial violent felons in california by
the way push for laws that people who
violently abuse our fellow citizens
have their right to vote we want to pack
the court we want d.c to be a state
bring in a record number of illegal
immigrants give them an immediate path
to citizenship
no voter id which every single other
super far left european nation looks at
us and says quoi
they have no idea how crazy this has
become
the american left is significantly
further left
than the european left now outside of
maybe
income taxes and abortion in some
countries you need to know how far we've
gone it's not that
oh the republicans have gone far further
right and the left has gone further left
it's the left has gone so far left that
the right
even going a little left which they are
republican donald trump
first president including obama by the
way to actually be
inaugurated supporting gay marriage for
crying out loud he was like the
runner-up was to to uh to uh
arsenio hall was cindy lopper she's only
done lesbian things for the last three
decades
pretty much she bops she bought it can
you imagine you know it's funny too
um this this website washington.org it's
like washington dc's official website
for like visiting dc
you know press sports all that stuff
yeah they say though a capital city it
is ironic that residents of washington
lack full self-governance and that's on
their history of washington dc paige
yeah they don't even know their own
history they don't know it's the
trade-off the danger of having it be its
own state you don't want that you don't
want a state exerting power over the
federal government that was the whole
point to begin with done
argument over move on well they don't
they don't believe in historical context
they don't believe in precedent they
don't believe in actual founding intent
in the country that's why they think
well actually if you look at the second
amendment
that says the right to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed the right of
the people right they go
actually we interpret this as meaning
that people have no right to own
firearms whatsoever
at all well how does that how does that
uh how do you how does that match with
the constitution like well that doesn't
yeah that that quote from this page
very nice oh geez all right so uh and
you guys can let us know what your
opinion is i want to hear what you
yeah what's the most convincing case
that you've heard for dc being a state
beyond i want i want i want i want
do you feel better educated give me give
me a state i need i need i'm doing the
work i'm not a slacker
hey uh smash that like button hey that's
right oh i did
right now if you're watching right now
live right now hit the like button
immediately
right now otherwise your children will
die you hate me
so here is let's move on to anti-asian
hate crimes remember this i don't know
if you guys remember this no
this happened and they were talking
about yeah i know it's not a way
and i haven't heard that but it was
speaking of cause i'm sure it was about
maybe a month and a half ago when they
started covering it after we were
covering it
saying we had to do something sorry
asian americans you've been
used but here let's go back to a time
when they cared about you
and a hate crime uh is we want to
document the hate crimes
asian-american hate has been as
organic to american history uh not as
long as
uh discriminating
to this country about in the middle of
the 19th century
i want everybody to watch this segment
because it's just it's outrageous the
nypd investigating what they say
is a hate crime assault against a 65
year old
asian woman who was punched and kicked
monday
in midtown manhattan by an attacker who
allegedly made
anti-asian statements towards her and
that's according to the police
it comes as the latest in a string of
anti-asian hate
and violence making this a crisis the
asian community
and their situation qualifications have
been getting worse james corden's only
qualification is adipose tissue
that church decay uh clip too he's like
you know asian
uh hate is as you know that's pretty
good it's it's it's part of american
history it says organic to american and
he's
a black producer and he's like oh i i
mean african-americans
but not as long as i mean y'all were
worse
what we have here is a failure to
communicate
i've been working on the railroad all
the live long
inappropriate permission to take it off
boss trick question
i'm not wearing bands look when they
built the wall they just threw the
bodies in the wall
it's not like we're the first people hey
what's going on on cnn that guy on the
left looks like he's uh he's appearing
through exclusively the left lens of 3d
glasses
that's actually uh 2080 morocco
so look this is one thing and we'll
actually give you a little bit of a
self-defense segment here in a couple of
minutes
on some of these crimes because a lot of
them are happening with blunt
instruments
which is pretty obviously disheartening
but keep in mind the mainstream media
and
you see this on cnn you see this
everywhere they tried to paint this as
what
what white supremacist right white
supremacy and there are quite a few
we're going to go through quite a few
examples of recent attacks that have
taken place really in the last week i
think the oldest one is 10 days old
and uh you'll notice that with the
articles they don't mention the race as
opposed to here the headlines that you
see that always have
white supremacist attack white person if
you read an article and they say they
have the suspect
or they've already charged the suspect
right the criminal
and it doesn't list their name or it
does it usually means they're not a
white person
because if it's white it will say white
just like in the entertainment industry
if someone doesn't espouse politics at
all
usually means they're more right leaning
because it's only a net positive
in the entertainment industry to say
that you're a democrat it's a virtue
signal that gains you
notoriety points same thing you put in
your article
white man commits insert group
marginalized group hate crime here
you gain points so it's important to
know we have all the sources available
at earthquaker.com you hit the link in
the description
so you can see the original sources for
some of these hate crimes um
something else too that facts matter
statistics matter
and we can't necessarily explain the
exact reason why
but if you are surprised to learn that
there's a little bit of tension between
the black american and asian american
community
perhaps you should check your dumb
[ __ ] privilege because this has been
going on for a very long time in this
country in san francisco where a lot of
these crimes have been taking place
over 85 percent of physical assault
crimes
all physical assault crimes against
asians were committed by
a black attacker nationally wow blacks
make up the largest percent of
perpetrators
of anti-uh i guess you would not anti of
violent crimes against asians look
sometimes it's a robbery and they happen
to be asian that's also a problem with
crime statistics because
they can just file it with under a hate
crime now well look what what was the
crime
murder doesn't need a footnote but we do
understand that there has been an
increase and they want you to believe
it's because of kung flu
or donald trump saying that this came
from meaning
being act being geographically accurate
like we've done with other diseases and
pandemics in the past yeah they want you
to think that donald trump was
up there with a topographical mask going
look that's where the yellows are
oh geez that was rough
youtube go to utah
you're going to get letters again you
know that one day mormon's the next
this was may 5th 85 year old chui fung
was stabbed while waiting for the bus
in chinatown by the way if you have
children i recommend they probably don't
stick around we don't
i don't think we show anyone here
obviously getting killed but uh there
are some
these are these are beatings that you
can find either on youtube or on these
news websites
i think it's important for you guys to
understand the context not a trigger
warning i just don't think kids should
be watching this
if especially if they're like you know
goonies little slick shoes they'll never
sleep again
so you know it is a stabbing warning it
is a stabbing
warning not not for not for this not for
this one not for this one
uh this is choi fong 85 year old uh was
beaten stabbed waiting for bus in
chinatown they don't specify the race
against sourceville attacks credit.com
wanna guess why the family of 85 year
old chu fong said she'd been waiting for
the bus tuesday evening after buying
groceries in chinatown
she's independent she's kind she's very
headstrong and she's if she has to do
something she's going to do it
so yeah that's just her this was true
grandson
he says he didn't want to show his face
feeling like his family has suddenly
been thrown into the spotlight
fong was stabbed at 4th and market
tuesday evening along with another 63
year old asian woman
both are expected to survive fong though
remains in the hospital
now you notice in that story they didn't
uh didn't give you the suspicion not at
all
well they know who it is 54 year-old
patrick thompson and he has a history of
deadly assault he has a history of
committing crimes oh there you go
oh well that's fine i'm sure they'll
just bring them into the police station
in new york and let them write out
right catch and release
also in san francisco uh this was may
5th dad pushing a stroller or san
francisco whatever
what did i say did i say san francisco i
said new york sydney
or san francisco did i say illegal
thanks for having my back
there's so many china towns there's so
many chinese
there's so many liberal hellholes it's
my bed
i can't feel a thing bill you can do it
all day can you do it all day
um san francisco dad pushing a stroller
punched until he fell to the ground uh
this is may 5th another clip
we are getting new exclusive
surveillance footage of another brutal
attack in san francisco now this one was
captured
at gus's market in mission bay on friday
check this out
police say an asian father who was
pushing his one-year-old
child in a stroller was suddenly beaten
to the ground
hey that guy has a good recovery though
yeah he does he got clipped i mean look
i'm not saying that he didn't go down
but he got up
he got up because his kid i mean can you
imagine this i have a son right now and
if somebody attacked me and was beating
me and my son's stroller started rolling
down shoot him
which is what just happened right there
yeah no i mean it's
unbelievable him are you encouraging
violence yes if someone attacks me
brutally while i'm there with my kid and
my kid is now in danger their stroller
can be rolling into the street
i'd no longer care if you were down on
your luck maybe you need some cash
doesn't matter bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang reload
bang
okay don't care that's what now i agree
it's unfortunate but that's what you
deserve if you attack somebody by the
way
attacker sydney hammond there uh he was
arrested only a couple of weeks ago
for uh assault and keep in mind this is
at a time in california when they are
releasing
over 70 000 felons numbers i don't have
the
entirely verified numbers low end
50-something thousand
high-end 60-something thousand violent
felons
tens of thousands of violent felons
being re-released onto the streets
and most of these examples are repeat
offenders now we can go to new york city
uh sorry i might have the name wrong
wait are you saying that there's a
connection between those who commit
violent crimes and those who commit
violent crime
it's like a choose your own path book it
is whatever answer you want
well you know what the ending is
huh no dave no i don't know also
abominable snowman don't wear sunscreen
that was an actual goosebumps choose
your own path book and it sucked
by the way speaking of choose your own
path or else here's what happens
is if it's a white attacker right this
is what happens right now if it's a
white attack or it's white supremacy
if it's a black attacker it's donald
trump it's a byproduct it's white
supremacy
yeah if it's an asian attacker they're
mad because people like us are talking
about the realistic crime statistics
regarding people who are perpetrating uh
anti-asian attacks against them and it's
white supremacy so if the answer is
always white supremacy
does the question really matter that's
where we are with the media okay
this is a new york city 61 year old yao
panma the attacker this one is look
tough to watch we may not want to run
the whole clip but you need to know
what's going on in this country right
now because the media has moved on
and i want asian americans out there to
be safe to have their head on a swivel
uh his head was stomped leaving him in
critical condition with um cerebral
contusions facial fractures
this is the oldest one april 25th
yeah all right that's enough we get the
point he keeps going and keep in mind
that if that man was then apprehended by
the police officers and
uh tried to get away and they roughed
him up a little bit those police
officers would be on trial for murder
and we would exclusively empathize with
him you don't believe me
go look at michael brown's rap sheet go
look at george floyd's rapture
just because you don't have the video of
the woman being pistol-whipped in front
of her kid when george floyd
committed an armed robbery doesn't mean
it didn't happen if you saw
george floyd doing that would you have a
different opinion how would you feel if
a cop
subdued that guy afterward as a matter
of fact how would you feel if after that
the cop said hey are you high as a kite
right now and he said no no officer and
he said all right
let me get you into this car let me get
you some air conditioning
you'd probably be pissed at the cops
going easy on them so you can't just
react based on emotion
but sometimes it's important to put that
emotional that visceral reaction
into context how would you want a cop to
treat that guy
well of course you know people are going
to react based on emotion that's what
that guy's doing right there he's
letting rage take over
and you're you're stomping a guy who's
already down yeah i don't even know if
it's rage or it's just a you know guy
knows that he's never gonna be held
accountable so hey it's good for me it's
free
it's it's free beating it's a lot of
people who go out though and fight
that you see where once the other
person's down they run back in that
wasn't a fight
no you know what i mean yeah i did i'm
not saying that was a fight i'm not
saying hey
this was a fight right if it was he's
making
cowards do this yes that's powers yeah
no absolutely right once they're down
cowards do this and cowards do it under
the cover of oh well you're a
marginalized group so uh
first we'll blame white people guess who
gets hurt both black people and white
people defund the police over 80
of them black americans want at least as
much police presence or more guess who
gets hurt
black people let's say it's white
supremacy so that uh we can talk about
agent
guess who gets hurt asian americans who
are actually being assaulted in
record numbers in san francisco 85
that's an important that's a
statistically significant number okay
are you saying that are you saying that
asian americans in san francisco should
if they're trying to stay safe or should
be
racially profiling yes absolutely that's
exactly what i'm saying i'm saying that
you should be racially profiling and
being aware if you're in neighborhoods
where there have been anti-asian hate
crimes
and there are a lot of people who are
black and you are asian i think that you
should be careful right now because 85
percent and it's a staggering rise in
crime in san francisco are being
committed against asians by black
americans
i think you need to be aware and you
need to understand the risks right now
and you need to hold your city
government
accountable who has stirred up and
fermented hatred okay
it's like oh are you hey look this guy
robbed the bank blonde here blue eyes
are you racial profiling yep
if 85 of all crimes in this area were
being committed against a specific group
of people
and they all looked like gerald i'd be i
would keep my head on a swivel for any
six foot
five guy with blonde hair blue eyes who
makes corny jokes
nine baltimore this is one and now we're
getting
into uh uh and by the way asian
americans out there comment below i want
to hear how
uh yeah how you've been been feeling
because we did this when we did the
segment a long time ago they were
talking about
how uh they were experiencing the
anti-asian sentiment or if they were at
all
has it changed and have you noticed that
the media has all of a sudden gone radio
silence so now in baltimore
bastion of hope that it is uh two korean
women were beaten with a brick
inside their own liquor store
all right there you go we've seen enough
so that's a brick again this is we're
going to do a segment here just on i'm
kind of keeping yourself safe
uh some self-defense scenarios being a
more situational awareness because a lot
of people out there don't really even
have the
forethought sometimes until they find
themselves in a bad situation a lot of
attacks are taking place with blunt
force instruments right now
yeah so household items it's what's
available they're not because these
what's happening is not people going out
necessarily saying hey i'm going to
attack uh an asian person where they
would have maybe a gun
or even a knife what's happening is
maybe an asian person says something
that they don't like
and they take it as a racist attack this
is how if you read some of these stories
this happened quite a bit
she said something anti-black and they
said i didn't say anything anti-black
this is going on and so
they feel justified uh in eliciting a
violent response and so that's where
what i got i got a brick
i got a hammer and uh actually here's a
another one
right now which is a hammer in new york
city leslie jones attacked two
asian women with a hammer
for no reason it looks like well they
gave a poor review of ghostbusters
they should have
now i uh i want to note that this is of
course not the first time that leslie
jones has uh
uh demonstrated anti-asian hate the
power of petty compels you
ah yeah oh geez we should have seen the
warning signs
um by the way these are two places two
places new york and anywhere in
california hell holes
both of them and baltimore but in
baltimore that will tell you
you can't own a firearm you know what
would have defended those people from
the guy with a brick i don't care
what you say to someone you don't have
the right to pick up a brick and start
beating somebody with it but you know
what it protected them instead of oh no
guys we got to get them out of the store
bang bang bang bang bang done whatever
you're not going to beat me with a brick
but what about craig with debo on friday
and i know that a lot of i think we have
this clip here i know so this is
i want you to understand that this is an
outlier this is an exception to the rule
where uh sometimes you can take your
crab or crane stance
uh to defend yourself slim
chance of it working working but i i
want you to see what it does
look that's just a wow powerful and by
the way that's not that it wouldn't do
that
though he got lucky it's not that it
worked it's that the the gentleman
attacking him was incredibly confused
that's all if you watch that whole this
is like 15 years old yeah breaker ebon's
world the guy just goes all right
guys going come on let's go let's go he
goes all right and he stands like this
and all of a sudden you see you see this
guy backing up he's like oh i ain't even
that mad though
all right so before so we're going to
start this here and then we're going to
go to a mug club
it's time to teach a little bit if you
find yourself uh
opposite a leslie jones uh with a hammer
or someone with a brick it's time to uh
show some
are you saying we don't have a stick
yeah i don't have a string but we're
gonna bring in smooth manny here
and uh show you what would be
appropriate to do in a situation with an
attacker like this smooth manny do we
have
who's come on in yeah come on there he
is powerful
yeah all right there he is smooth man
he's powerful okay so uh let's have you
move in here i'm gonna take off my
headphones
all right and you guys can ask any
questions of course i'm gonna take off
my firearm right now did you like the
all-female ghostbusters
that's us if he answers yes i think we
should beat him yeah
we're definitely allowed to kick him
once he's down you're seeing a lot of
this happening with blunt force
instruments right you've seen this
happen with bricks here you can give me
the knife uh i wanted like a malice i
paid for
many many years of self-defense as a kid
yeah and ultimately would just get my
ass kicked
because it would teach you useless crap
with a knife
your only option is to run can i ask a
serious question yeah
is joe lewis going to be okay with this
probably not but so he'll be
he'll be fine don't worry he'll attack
you the issue with the knife is run
right if someone's trying to attack you
with a knife run because here's the
thing
people tell you you can defend yourself
against a knife it doesn't require any
inertia
this is a bleed out this is a bleed out
this is a kill
okay yeah people need to understand you
have a better chance against someone
with a gun
than do against someone with a knife
they're there they slice you no matter
what now
it changes when it's a brick or a hammer
because it's a blunt force instrument
so what does that require requires
inertia
yeah and so now what people need to do
first off the best thing you can do is
run away
but inertia requires it requires
movement and hitting right at the
extension right
of that sort of momentum that blow so
that's what you want to avoid
people out there who haven't gone to a
brazilian jiu jitsu class i recommend
you go or judo they teach you sort of
distance and timing
maybe sometimes even some karate um so
what you would have to do here is treat
manny like he's george foreman
okay in other words he doesn't have a
knockout blow but he does with a hammer
right yeah i use mario circa donkey kong
whatever year that was true
so what you want to do is you don't want
to get if i can get into boxing range
you see people talking about this on
you see this on youtube right what i'm
going to do look is i'm going to jab
and i got tiger claw and monkey fist
well you're gonna get your ass beat
either get away completely or you want
to be close in that distance so i don't
want to be in punching range
what i want is to keep him away from me
until i close
so this is where i would use my leg my
lead leg
because i know that he's not in punching
now i'm not talking about doing you know
boom question mark kick anything like
that
nothing fancy it's a push kick as he
comes in right i push off his hip right
now i've got a bad knee so let's be
careful yeah
but you want to kick him away keep him
at distance
step back so you know you're not in that
range yeah
get away if you can if you can't let's
say you're in a store
like happened with the ladies with the
guy with the brick right so i can't get
distance i can't run away if it's a
knife you're screwed don't care what the
krav maga guys tell you you can't fight
you're done
guy with a knife beats a guy without a
knife for in a store
what do i need to do do i want to be
right here no
i want to watch that wind up stay out
miss at least once i'm probably going to
get hit and come in and now close it
because look
less inertia yeah with the hammer and
this is where we can go into you need to
start training and grappling
some kind of hey joe lewis it's all good
well and steven a good point here is
that you're not necessarily going to get
out unscathed
at least you're not going to get the
knockout blow right by having some
distance
this is why i would say using this push
kick to keep them away is not going to
do anything with a knife because they
can still
cut right right and cut and i'm going to
bleed out no matter what that's true but
with the brick
with a the the good side to this is it
going to be a little bit slower
yeah so they're going to be telegraphing
like if you watch leslie jones
everything like
and in which case just a little bit of
head movement and then learn how to keep
yourself safe
once you clinch them up tie them up
really simple ways you go over under
boom once i get in and tie them up just
like a clinch right here see yeah
i have an overhook oh it's now he might
hit my back with a hammer
but it's not nearly as bad of a knockout
blow right exactly
down if you want at this point learn how
to handle them on the ground
but the most important thing is getting
away in that case in new york you know
what i saw
scaffolding oh yeah use that yeah use
that put that between you
and the attacker like do some spider-man
stuff and like jump up and no don't jump
get around it get around and do this
right like the old pirate clock on the
old uh
the old parts of the caribbean ride
where the guy's chasing his beer went
right do this until the cop gets there
unless you're in a municipality where
they defunded the police in which case
kiss your ass goodbye
so we're going to continue with some of
this some questions we'll take in chat
on mug club everyone right now leave a
comment and sharing
is caring look at joe lewis he's good
you know he's you guys you're
fine joe lewis i'm gonna be gone monday
dave lou
dave landau is uh filling in but uh love
you youtube we'll uh see you later piss
off